[Music]
calling ghostbuster fans everywhere a
new movie is on the way and let me tell
you people are losing their minds dogs
and cats living together mass hysteria
no here is the magic of our eg balls we
were on the set of the original 35 years
ago yeah let's be clear no other show
has that and no other show knows more
about the Ghostbusters then and now this
is the new sneak peek teaser of the
Ghostbusters sequel in the works
the rusty remains of the original ecto-1
car is just one of the clues that this
film will be a love letter to the 1984
classic another clue that music outside
the barn is the same score used in the
opening library scene
[Music]
ivan reitman of course was the famed
director behind the original movies see
that 11-year old boy by his side at the
ghostbusters to premiere
well that's jason reitman and he is
writing and directing this next chapter
he's developed into such a mature
knowing filmmaker his writing is really
extraordinary he has learned the film
will begin shooting in the next few
months with a 2020 release date jason
says his film takes place in the present
day Ghostbusters is going to be a very
very funny movie
absolutely funny scary thrills and
chills for the whole family and a PG
rating we hope Petey was on the massive
set of the original film in 1984
[Music]
Oh strike that dan aykroyd and Bill
Murray could tell they had a hit on
their hands his character dr. Venkman in
the movie is a skeptic and is not afraid
of ghosts no no I'm not scared of ghosts
I am line to look back I am ready for
another and by the way the theme song
y'all hear it it was written and
performed by Ray Parker jr. it hit
number one and listen to this news it
was nominated for an Oscar deservedly
yes indeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]